are you a person who eats the frosting
but
leaves the cake untouched
or steals all the sugar packets at a
restaurant
if your sweet tooth decides your meal
plan
chances are you're not concerned about
having a vegetable medley on the side
what you want is the dopamine hit that
comes with
every spoonful of that delicious white
gold but
what if you only ate sugar
for a month how much sugar would you
have to eat
each day could you lose weight
and is there such thing as a sugar coma
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you ate nothing but sugar for a month
[Music]
the american heart association
recommends that
women eat less than 25 grams of added
sugar daily
and 36 grams for men
so considering a 355 milliliter can of
soda contains 47.2 grams of sugar
you might be living above average
already
but if the only thing you eat is sugar
you'll need about 2 000 calories each
day to keep your body running
and if you were to hit that magic number
what would happen to your body your
inner child might be overjoyed at an all
sugar diet but your inner organs
would be screaming for mercy let's be
clear we're not talking about replacing
asparagus with twizzlers and using dr
pepper as your mouthwash
this diet is only refined sugar
not sugar-filled foods we'll let you
drink water too
so if you're going to get the calories
you need to keep your body functioning
you'll have to consume 532 grams of
sugar per day
that's 222 sugar cubes
for breakfast lunch dinner and
all your snacks in between
if you want to avoid cavities you'll
need to brush your teeth
more than twice a day if you don't brush
more often
the bacteria in your mouth will feed off
the sugar
and leave behind an acid that will
destroy the enamel on your teeth
in the short term the release of
endorphins would give your body a surge
of energy after
every meal and you might not be able to
sleep at night
but over time all that sugar
could have a downside you might not
expect
your body could get addicted to this
white stuff
when the month ends and you return to
eating real food
you're likely to go through withdrawal
so prepare to feel intense irritability
fogginess moodiness and low energy
you may not gain any weight from eating
2 000 calories of sugar each day but you
could develop a chronic condition like
diabetes
according to harvard health publishing a
high sugar diet
may even stimulate your liver to dump
more harmful fats into your bloodstream
with all this sugar pouring through your
body and
more harmful fats you would have a
higher risk for heart disease
your blood pressure and your insulin
levels would raise so high
your blood vessels would become less
flexible
your kidneys would store excessive water
and sodium
and if blood isn't pumping properly
through your body
it could affect your love life as well
just saying
and let's not forget about your red
blood cell count
which would be significantly lower
why does that matter well with fewer red
blood cells
you wouldn't be able to heal from wounds
you could lose
a lot more blood due to excessive
bleeding or
get infections every bruise scrape
or paper cut could send you to the
hospital
or even the morgue and
a 2018 study from new zealand's
university of
otega suggests that glucose hurts your
cognitive abilities
while your body may be awake a
sugar coma takes a toll on your
attention and your memory
and without vitamin c in your meals
you're likely to develop scurvy which
will make you feel
tired on top of that since you're not
eating protein
your muscles will start to waste away
and your bones will get weaker without
minerals in your diet
the sugar would also attach to the
proteins you
already had in your blood and create
harmful molecules known as
advanced glycation end products or ages
these end products would damage the
collagen and elastin in your skin
leaving you wrinkled and saggy
now if you're an 81 kilogram american
and
you eat two and a half kilograms of
sugar in one meal
you've got a 50 50 chance of a lethal
overdose
those odds aren't sweet
so stick to a healthy diet plan and you
won't come
close to that lethal amount
realistically though
a month is about all your body could
take of this kind of abuse
before you succumb to disease or
malnutrition
but you don't have to give up sugar
completely though
as long as you're not putting your
health in harm's way
you can safely enjoy an occasional treat
or sugary reward
just quit dipping your finger in the
frosting before the cake is served
gross okay so now you're back
on a regular meal plan veggies and all
but what if you stopped brushing your
teeth
well that's a story for another
what if
you